o uso da meia elástica é de suma
importância eu atendo muitos pacientes
aqui no consultório que estavam ou que
já tiveram trombose e não usaram meia
elástica durante o período por que que é
importante a meia elástica porque se eu
tenho uma ou mais veias entupidas as
outras veias vão fazer o trabalho
daquela então elas precisam de uma
melhora da pressão de drenagem então
quando eu uso a meia elástica eu melhoro
a pressão de drenagem nas veias que não
estão entupidas e nisso eu minimizo e
muito as sequelas da trombose Quais são
as sequelas da trombose uma perna
inchada permanentemente deformidade
dessa perna varises
importantes linfedema que é aquela perna
inchada aquele pezinho de elefante
dermatite Ocre que é aquela perna escura
Tá certo então o uso da meia elástica
minimiza as sequelas